[Music]
honey a new book Arnold Schwarzenegger
says his first clue that the
housekeepers son was his was when the
boy started looking like him
yeah his second clue was when he was the
only Mexican kid with an Austrian accent
oh no it's only the aim that's insane I
just love I keep coming back to the
image of a little Arnold Spohr yeah yeah
yeah it's the funniest child you can
imagine I love California
candidates preparing hard for the
presidential debate for tomorrow's
debate President Obama's advisors have
been working with him to keep his
responses short yeah in fact the only
words the president's plans on saying
are bin Laden and dead presidential
debates will be streamed live on YouTube
and we're gonna watch it on YouTube yeah
as a result both candidates have been
busy learning how to dance Gangnam style
big celebrities getting involved in the
campaign Beyonce and Jennifer Lopez are
gonna star in a new campaign ad for
President Obama yeah nice yeah Mitt
Romney said though he's upset they're
not supporting him he still loves those
two tennis-playing sisters
did I say something wrong
[Applause]
what did I say wrong this time I've
worked very hard on my Romney impression
the the lead singer of the 90s band
creed has said he thinks President Obama
is ineffective now in other words
President Obama lost the support of yet
another unemployed person he Manama from
I hear there was no other songs there's
a whole bunch of bands at that time and
I you know I was old at that I was still
old then yeah and I'd stop India 77
years old you're describing like six
bands yeah like six hurt there was a
period of time in the 90s when every
lead singer was a donkey yeah yeah sure
Mohammed rule Joe Biden campaigning very
hard for Obama in Florida Vice President
Joe Biden told a group of nurses if
there are any angels in heaven they're
all nurses then vine said of course
maybe they wouldn't be in heaven if it
had better nurses swear he lost the
crowd
tough times for Oprah Winfrey did you
hear this settle down Andy she's gonna
be fine because okay I can go to her
right now
you'll never get over that hedge Oprah
ladies and gentlemen is now 50th 50th on
Fortune's list of most powerful women in
business yeah
in a related story Oprah just released
Oh magazine's list of 49 women to
destroy kill them kill them all but
she's probably still on the cover going
like yeah in a recent interview Daniel
Craig Daniel Craig said he can't do
things like get drunk or go
skinny-dipping because he's too
well-known when asked for comment women
everywhere said he can go skinny-dipping
The Weather Channel is trying to start a
new trend of naming winter storms winter
storms will be named yeah which is great
because I've always wanted to hear a
weatherman say stay indoors there's
eight inches of Conan coming your way
[Applause]
you
[Applause]